“The bigger, the better!” is a phrase
you will not hear from a researcher at the
SCP Foundation.
Larger anomalies can be a nightmare to secure,
contain, and protect, and if you’re new
around here, that’s kind of the Foundation’s
whole thing.
But how broad is the spectrum of anomalous
size?
What deadly things come in small packages,
and what anomalous threats could lay waste
to the world in a footstep?
These are exactly the ideas we’re exploring
today with our big question: What’s the
biggest SCP?
Alright, now let’s set a few ground rules
before we jump headlong into the action: No
entirely anomalous planets or alternate dimensions.
This may seem like we’re excluding anomalies
like SCP-2935, O’ Death, the alternate dimension
where death itself has overtaken everything,
or SCP-4774, a theoretical anomalous gas giant
that’s two to four times the diameter of
Earth.
But it’s a little unfair to some of the
other hard-working big SCPs by skewing the
results with whole universes or literal celestial
bodies.
We’re also excluding shapeshifters and reality
warpers who could, theoretically, be any size
they like.
If you have a problem with that, we kindly
invite you to take it up with the director
of our complaint department: SCP-106.
For those who haven’t now been dragged into
a pocket dimension to endure centuries of
unspeakable horrors, we’ll start with the
pipsqueaks, and work our way up to the “Oh
lawd, he comin’” stage of anomalous size.
Our hard-working researchers have concluded,
through rigorous study, that one of the most
itty bitty SCPs is undeniably SCP-008: A terrifying
prion with incredible infectivity rates that
effectively turns its victims into Walking
Dead-style zombies, with the only known cure
being SCP-500.
Prions are beyond tiny, at only around 253
amino acids in length.
They can only be seen via an electron microscope,
and they make viruses look beefy by comparison.
That doesn’t mean if you get infected it
won’t seriously mess up your day, to put
it extremely, extremely lightly.
So, what’s next?
We’ve got something like SCP-165, also known
as the Creeping, Hungry Sands of Tule.
We know what you’re thinking.
Seriously, we have the technology for that.
And we know you’re thinking: “Hey, that’s
a lot of sand, what do you mean that’s only
one step above a virus?”
That’s because this ersatz sand is actually
made up of tiny parasitic mites only about
seven hundred fifty micrometers in length.
But once again, don’t let their tiny size
fool you.
They can knock you out and eat you to the
bone in minutes!
But hey, at least they’ll leave bones, unlike
the nightmarish flying ant creatures coming
out of SCP-743, the chocolate fountain.
This fountain - which is perfect for weddings,
corporate retreats, and birthday parties for
your worst enemies - has the most delicious
chocolate you’ve ever tasted.
Problem is, if you ever ingest it, millions
of these nightmarish, ant-like monsters will
swarm in soon after, and devour you and everyone
you love.
The body-horror earwigs of SCP-439 are in
this same weight class, as monsters with the
size and general appearance of pre-existing,
non-anomalous insects.
Except you don’t need to have a phobia of
them for these little suckers to make your
worst nightmares come true.
But you know who loves bugs?
Birds!
Birds such as the common corn crake, like
SCP-2337, also known as Dr. Spanko - Though
Dr. Spanko prefers bugs of the gummy variety.
He can also literally talk you to death, with
a voice so loud and booming it’ll destroy
your very cells if you’re exposed to it
for too long.
But his body isn’t too long, at a manageable
27–30 cm.
He’s a similar size to other fun little
critters like SCP-131, the Eye Pods, and less
fun little critters, like SCP-689, the Haunter
in the Dark.
The weight and height class above this is
one that a huge number of SCPs fall into:
Roughly human, or a little above or below.
The Old Man, Cain, Able, God, The Sculpture,
The Plague Doctor, The Tickle Monster, The
Swamp Woman, and Bigfoot.
And just above that, we’ve got a number
of the SCP Heavy Hitters: SCP-096, SCP-682,
Fernand the Cannibal, Cthulhu, SCP-5031, Major
Alexei Belitrov, the list goes on.
But honestly, these are all still small potatoes.
We’re playing with the Big Boys now, literally.
What follows are some of the biggest SCPs
our in-house Foundation scientists could find,
from “Dear god, that’s huge” to so big
that your mind might boil in your head like
an egg just trying to comprehend it.
What are we waiting for?
Let’s make like Gaston and get large!
First, we head to SCP-1730, the nightmarish,
interdimensional Site-13.
No, we’re not going to cop out and hit you
with a building, we’re thinking more about
one of its scariest occupants: The giant,
bloodthirsty monster known as Leech Boy.
Once an anomalous child named Elijah, the
abomination is now a 200-meter-long broodmother
with a hive mind controlling swarms of deadly
anomalous leeches.
Even in a building literally full of terrifying
anomalous monsters, Leech Boy was able to
dominate with his size and power.
Until, of course, he ran into the next entry
on this list: SCP-001 - The Gate Guardian.
This cosmic, celestial flame warrior stands
at 700 cubits tall - Which equates to an incredible
320 meters.
Over half the height of the Empire State Building!
If his hotter-than-the-sun greatsword doesn’t
get you, he can always just step on you, and
believe us, there will be literally nothing
left after he does so.
It makes sense, after all.
You really don’t want a pipsqueak guarding
the Gates to Paradise!
But what’s a servant of the Gods to an actual,
bonafide God?
Let’s take a look at another SCP-001 that
proves to be terrifyingly big: Straight from
the Ouroboros Cycle, SCP-001 Apotheosis, also
known as The Broken God.
We don’t have exact numbers on the size
of this giant, metal monstrosity, largely
due to the fact that it kept getting bigger
and bigger as it integrated more matter into
its already massive body.
The sheer scale of this utter behemoth is
best expressed in what it was capable of doing,
and what it took to eventually put it down.
The monster caused considerable chaos across
all of Western Mexico, leading to the largest
deployment of Amnestics after the fact in
SCP Foundation history.
In order to eventually beat the thing, they
needed to get a hand from a certain other
anomaly, but we’ll discuss that one a little
more later in the video.
If you thought that a giant metal monstrosity,
nicknamed “The World Eater” by some, is
scary, then you’ll be quaking in your boots
at the mere thought of our next SCP: SCP-4006
- Massachusetts.
This incredibly anomalous state is afflicted
by a probabilistic anomaly known as The Veil,
which is meant to maintain a sense of normalcy,
and tricks people into thinking that the state
of Massachusetts has ever been occupied by
humans.
In fact, the location has been entirely devoid
of human civilization since the dawn of time,
we’re all just victims of the anomaly that
makes us think otherwise!
Our next contestant isn’t wider than the
anomalous state of Massachusetts, but he’s
a hell of a lot taller, and way, way, way
more dangerous.
It’s the apocalyptic monster trapped beyond
SCP-2317 - The Devourer of Worlds.
This monster is likely destined to perform
an XK-Class End of the World scenario against
us, as it already has in other worlds.
It’s an utterly monstrous 200 kilometers
tall - Think 400 empire state buildings stacked
on top of each other, and then some.
It’s a being that likely no weapon humanity,
or even the SCP Foundation, has devised will
be able to even slow down.
If ever he breaks free, we can only hope that
death will come quickly…
But his size is nothing compared to some of
the beasts that lurk below!
Take the legendary SCP-3000, the godlike underwater
being known to some as Anantashesha.
This huge, eel-like monster is the leading
provider of amnestics for the SCP Foundation,
as long as they can provide it with ample
sacrifices in return.
It’s a being so big and so deep underwater
that it’s difficult to truly know the creature’s
length, some estimates have put it around
or even above an incredible 900 kilometers
- That’s over twice the length of a fellow
anomaly: the state of Massachusetts.
It’s a perfect example of some of the terrifying
things waiting underneath.
So what if we told you there was something
even longer, even larger than the terrifying
Anantashesha, lurking below us as you watch
this very video?
And furthermore, what if we told you that
it was super adorable, too?
Meet SCP-2952, also known as the Infinite
Corgi.
This male Pembroke Welsh Corgi measures over
30,000 kilometers in length.
That’s a hell of a lot of Good Boy, where
could we possibly put it all?
Well, his head and front legs protrude adorably
from the ground in Portland, Oregon, and his
30,000 kilometers of corgi body place his
rear end in a rural area of Japan's Kariwa
District.
His body weaves under the Americas, Europe,
and much of Asia, putting the length of Anantashesha
to shame.
There’s a lot more to SCP-2952 than we can
really get into here, but if you want a full
video on the world’s longest Good Boy, sound
off about it in the comments.
And now we’re down to the big three.
The ones that could drive you mad even trying
to comprehend their scale.
Try to take it all in, if they can even fit
into your field of vision.
While this next anomaly isn’t as long as
the Infinite Corgi, its sheer bulk is terrifying
on a whole different level.
It’s SCP-169, also known as The Leviathan.
Thankfully, this incredible beast is lying
dormant underneath an archipelago, but like
the world’s various scary supervolcanoes,
the risk of the Leviathan someday rising and
causing chaos across the globe with its mere
movements is never out of the question.
Just in terms of sheer, raw largeness, SCP-169
is probably the biggest anomaly currently
living on earth.
But that doesn’t mean we’re done just
yet.
For our next two shining examples of megalophobia-inducing
monstrosity, we need to head a little further
out into the cosmos.
First, to the creature sucking the life out
of the giant star that gives all of us life:
SCP-1682, also known as the Solar Parasite.
This monster is described by personnel on
the case as a kind of cosmic tapeworm that
siphons energy out of stars like our sun.
It’s over 28,000 kilometers long, and there’s
a good chance that it means us great harm.
Just goes to show: There are no good tapeworms,
whether they’re wreaking havoc on your intestines
or your entire solar system.
And now, the big daddy to end all big daddies,
the biggest SCP that isn’t a planet, dimension,
or portion of space: SCP-2399, an unimaginably
huge weapon of mass destruction known as A
Malfunctioning Destroyer.
This alien superweapon, sent to completely
destroy the earth, instead ended up getting
stranded on Jupiter and causing a mark on
the surface known as the Great Red Eye - Which,
by the way, is bigger than the entirety of
planet earth.
It’s currently being repaired, and if ever
it completes its goal, it will likely continue
its mission and wipe us all out.
To give you an idea of just how much more
powerful this mechanized alien nightmare is
compared to pretty much everything else on
this list: SCP-2399 was instrumental in defeating
and eventually destroying SCP-001 Apotheosis,
the Broken God.
Seeing as it’s currently 713,000,000 miles
away, it’s difficult to tell exactly how
big SCP-2399 is.
But one thing is for sure: If ever you get
close enough to find out, you’re as good
as dead.
So, there you have it: The biggest SCPs out
there.
Which was your favorite?
Let us know down in the comments.
Oh, and if you’re new here, be sure to subscribe.
It can make a big difference.
Now go check out “SCP-2935 O, Death and
More Epic SCP Stories You Can't Miss” and
“SCP-002 The Living Room & the Most Terrifying
SCP Rooms” for more unforgettable anomalous
compilations from SCP Explained!